[Musik]
hallo meine lieben ich möchte die
erdbeersaison ja so richtig ausnutzen
deswegen gab es auch schon ein paar
rezepte und heute gibt auch eins und
zwar ein schnelles notebook erdbeer
dessert und dafür fange ich jetzt auch
direkt an gar nicht lange drumherum
quatschen hier habe ich meine kalte
schlagsahne alle ganze menge angaben
findet ihr wie immer unten in der video
beschreibung hier habe ich meine kalte
schlagsahne
es ist natürlich immer gut wenn die
schlagsahne kalt ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank kommt nicht zehn minuten
stehen lassen und dann erschlagen und
was sie auch immer mache das sage ich
euch immer gerne öfter auch als tipp ich
gebe die schüssel in den kühlschrank für
zehn minuten und den schneebesen
aussieht dann kann euch nichts mehr
schief gehen beim aufschlagen von sahne
so ich lass das jetzt steif schlagen
eine minute lang dass man seine festen
regeln und dann muss ja noch eine halbe
minute und dann ist es richtig schön
steil
[Musik]
susanne ist steif die kommen ganz kurz
an die seite und weiter geht es mit dem
nächsten zu tat nicht pc mascarpone weil
ich finde es gibt noch mal so richtig
schönes und gefühlen ist sehr sehr
cremig deswegen gebe ich jetzt
mascarpone in meine schüsse und um das
ganze so ein bisschen aufzulockern und
damit auch nicht so schwer im magen
liegt möchte ich das mit ein bisschen
quark verrühren und ich finde quark und
sahne hallo klaus kröll und sagen es ist
für mich ein schönes trio ja
[Musik]
so da gehen wir noch puderzucker für die
süße dazu und vanille extrakt für den
geschmack und anschließend ca 30
sekunden lang mit dem schneebesen
verrühren bis schön cremig wird und dann
heben wir die sonne unter und dann nimmt
durch am besten ein teig fertig ist die
creme wie lange haben wir jetzt
gebraucht für alles haben sie vier
stunden stunde drei minuten minuten
schon alles okay haben das hemd und so
und dieses jahr rück mal die schüssel
nach links und sie die welt mit sie ihr
zuhause hat bis zu diesem schritt drei
minuten gebraucht so und jetzt geht es
weiter
jetzt wird einfach nur noch geschichte
hat leute das ist so easy ich habe jetzt
mal ein bug rahmen hier eingestellt auf
25 x 25 cm und jetzt habe ich hier ich
hab nennt man biscuits hohem auch
wirklich nutzen
die katzen sind wir anders die manche
aber auch gerne bis kreuzung könnte doch
löffelbiskuits oder eure lieblings keks
zu nehmen wichtig ist das ist jetzt in
milch punkt damit sie ja halt ein
bisschen weich werden die werden auch
durch die creme nach dem krieg zeit weil
sie brauchen doch also liegt nur eine
sekunde so 1 rausnehmen abtropfen lassen
und dann hier auf den boden gehen und
dann werde ich einfach nur die hälfte
der creme bestreichen
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich die erste hälfte der
creme glatt verstrichen und machen wir
eigentlich wieder das gleiche
das heißt wieder die wie hießen jetzt
noch mal die zunge diskret in richtung
eine ganze schicht vormachen und dann
die restlichen kinder darüber geben und
ihr könnt jetzt beim einer spezial
palette 2.0 nicht nur hier vorne die
spitze zum verstreichen benutzen das
heißt ihr könnt nicht nur hier in die
ecken ran sondern ihr nehmt auch jetzt
hier im 90 grad winkel und könnte dann
mit der seite ebenfalls verstreichen so
als nächstes schneiden wir frische
erdbeeren also ich finde sie ihr können
sie aber auch nur einmal halbieren ganz
wie ihr möchtet und gibt es jetzt auf
die oberfläche und gleich kommt noch ein
tortenguss dem zeige ich euch aber
gleich am herzen
[Musik]
die erdbeeren sind drauf und das sieht
jetzt so auch schon richtig schick aus
aber ich mache auf jeden fall ein
trocken wo es drauf weil erstens
schmeckt mir einfach und zweitens ist
die torte somit ein bisschen länger
haltbar aber wenn ihr die erdbeeren an
schneidet dann sind sie ganz schnell
nicht mehr haltbar da muss man das
sofort essen und so bleibt die torte
kühl gelagert drei tage lang haltbar
das heißt im umkehrschluss ihr könnt sie
auch einen tag zum beispiel vorher
vorbereiten
da kommt die frage nämlich auch mal ganz
oft so für den tortenguss benötigen wir
sauerkirsch schafft einfach deswegen
weil der rot ist und ich möchte einen
roten tortenguss und da gebe ich jetzt
eine packung magazine reihen das
entspricht 10 gramm mal rein rötlichen
freie und dann den herd einschalten und
das ganze zwei minuten lang sprudelnd
kochen und dann fängt es nämlich nach
dem kühlen anzuziehen man aktiviert ist
quasi durch dieses zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen lassen
nachdem zwei minuten habe ich das ganze
auch noch mal zehn minuten stehen lassen
damit ich das jetzt nicht ganz so heiß
auf meine erdbeeren gebe genau ansonsten
müsst ihr nichts beachten ich nehme
jetzt einfach einen löffel und gibt es
vorsichtig drüber und anschließend kommt
das zum kühlen in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
so und jetzt ab in den kühlschrank damit
für mindestens eine stunde besser sind
zwei dann kann noch mal alles schön fest
werden alles zieht schönen gesunden
biscuits 1
die tonnen glas sowie die fest und alles
wird einfach optimal zum vernaschen und
ich denke dass euch dieses rezept auch
sehr gut gefällt weil es ein praktisch
ist anfänger freundlich wenige zutaten
und rucki zucki nach dem backen dann
einfach den bug vom user nehmen und imba
kram entfernen und dann könnt ihr euch
das in beliebig große stücke einteilen
ich wünsche euch viel freude beim
nachmachen mit elastischen video ein
deutscher ein deutschen nach oben und
ein kostenloses abo guter alter der
kamera gefunden
ja wir haben konzentriert sogar zum euch
jetzt ganz viel freude beim nachmachen
und beim nächsten mal sehen wir uns dann
wieder hier auf geht s kitchen typen
kiki
[Musik]